I want to talk about the perception of
crowdfunding you know now you have
people with established films turning to
it as an alternate way and also a way of
gathering fan support but I will
sometimes there's been backlash like oh
it's begging for donations which is a
word I know we don't want to use but how
are you able to transcend that
perception well for me I mean I bring to
the table I like a lot of credibility
and it's not my first film and I feel as
if it's a it's a there's a film that
deals with the social issue and if
people are interested in seeing my work
and they're aware of me and they want to
support me or support you know films
that a filmmaker that has been through
Sundance and been through the film
festivals and as has done this for
several years that that I think it's
it's a platform that is appropriate for
films like this and for people like me
the other side of that is it develops
there's a sweet spot I think for people
for crowdfunding and then there's the
extremes you have your celebrities who
use it because they know they have a
fan-based and they know that they're
going to get so much support no matter
what and then you have the the people
with no credibility with no you know
it's may not be their fault it's just
they haven't you know we're all
encouraged in our life that we can do
whatever we want that we are entitled to
achieve our dreams and we can do this
and we can do that and with crowdfunding
it's you know people think that oh well
now that's that's the answer to my
question I just put my project up there
and since I'm entitled to have a dream
I'm entitled to write a book or make a
movie or be a ballet dancer put on my
theatre production that people now are
going to give me money and they don't
understand that that's just part of it
in order you know you have to
demonstrate that
you deserve that you've earned that
you've earned your place in a sense and
she gets you know right now Kickstarter
has over 130,000 projects that's a lot I
mean that is a lot so the big boys are
going to get the press you know the
spike lee's and the zach braff's they're
going to get the press they're never
going to have a problem using
Kickstarter to their advantage and I
really think they are using it to their
advantage it's not illegal they're
people they can that's fine but they're
using it to their advantage and there's
no doubt about it and then so and
there's people like me who that's sort
of the sweet spot I think Kickstarter
was meant for people like me whether I
mean I'm a filmmaker whether you're a
writer who's who is very prolific and
has a following but random house won't
give them a deal Kickstarter's perfect
with them or a ballet dancer or a
theater company that puts on great shows
but they need money to sustain their
season you know they need money for the
next season that's what Kickstarter's
for you know people who have shown that
they can really benefit from the
public's health and by doing that by
making contribution you're going to get
something back that you know is real and
tangible like oh I'm going to give XYZ
theatre company 40 bucks because I've
been to one of their shows and i'm going
to i know i'm going to like that show so
here's forty dollars i may not see the
show until six months but i'm helping
them you know what i mean a guy like
zach braff that movie's gonna get made
no matter what you know or whatever so
hope that answers your question yeah no
that's perfect
you